Nó này 2.3 năm 2018, thông tin từ công an tình quảng chi đơn vị vừa ra quy định tạm sữa hình sự muốn đối tượng,
hồ ngọt phân, hồ văn nàn, hồ quan đặt và hồ văn phủ, cùng chú tại sát hiểu ra tình quảng chi để đưa tra về hình viết người và trên giấu tội phạm.
Chứ đó, bao khoảng 18,5 năm 2018, nhau đối tượng trên giủ nhau đi trở tại Kyl Mét 1 mốt của lộ chiến.
Chứ khi đi, đặt qua về nhà lễ 1 khẩu xung án và đưa cho văn cơ sứ, cả nhóm dí chuyển bằng 2 xe 1 tồ đến Kyl Mét 3 mốt, thuộc địa bản thường KH, xa hữ hiệp tình quảng chi.
Nhóm này, dừng lại bên lề đường để sự dụng định thoại thì gặp anh 1 văn tê, chú cùng đưa phương, 2 bên xe ra 1 thấn.
Anh tê dụng mũ bảo hiểm đánh vào người văn.
Ngay lập tức, văn dú khẩu xung tự trồng áo khó bán anh tê gục tại chỗ.
Sâu đó, nát nhiên được đưa đi cấp kêu như đã từ văn xo với thương quán nạc, sau khi về an, văn cùng đường bọn bỏ chúng khỏi hiện trường và xấu 2 xe 1 tồ và lòng công thuát nước,
phú mà khẩu xung đến xấu tại nhà 1 mốt người dân trong thôn.
Cơ đời tự xo đỏ trở về nhà 1 hồ như không có chuyện gì sẽ ra.
Bối tinh thành khẩn chương, nhé trong truy bắt đối tượng, chỉ xói gần bốn dờ đồng hồ trong về vết mưa báo, đêm tối, lực lượng công an phối hợp với các lực lượng liên quan đã bắt bốn đối tượng.
Tăng bật tu được hồm một khẩu xung an, năm vinh đã 2 xe 1 tồ, để thoại gì đồng và một số tăng bật liên quan.
Hình vùng việc đang được lực lượng chức năng xử liên thè đúng quy định của pháp lật.